AND START THIS HEARING TODAY ON
AUGUST THIRTEENTH THIRTEEN
THIRTIETH.
AND WILL CALL THE MEETING TO
ORDER.
OUT WE HAVE.
WITH ENOUGH MEMBERS HERE FOR A
QUORUM OKAY TAKE THE ROLE.
CHECK QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
HERE CHUCK WORKS OVER HERE
MEISTER ALLEN BERMAN.
BERMAN HERE CERVANTES GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PRESENT
RODRIGUEZ STEINORTH [inaudible]
STEINORTH HERE.
BUT I'M SURE WE HAVE QUORUM.
YOU WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGAN WE
HAVE ONLY ONE BILL.
ITEM AB TWO SEVEN SIX TO WHEN WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREO HERE
[inaudible]
SHARE.
WOULD HELP LOCAL BUSINESSES
GROVER CHRISTIAN THE VISUALS
VARIOUS TWO EMPLOYMENT TO
DISABILITIES INCARCERATION AND
HOMELESSNESS.
THIS BILL WILL UPLIFT WITNESSES
THAT DISTINGUISHES ITSELF BY
PROMOTING A PRODUCT [inaudible]
AT WITH ME HERE TO PRESENT IS
FAITH CALLING FROM ONE OF THE
BEST COUNTIES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE LOS ANGELES CA
[inaudible]
THE THANK YOU.
I'LL JUST ADD I WE'RE LOOKING
FOR CONCURRENCE AND WE
APPRECIATE --
THE WORK OF THE ATTORNEY
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AS WELL AS
A CHAIR SO THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE ANY OTHERS HERE
IN SUPPORT.
ON ANYBODY OPPOSED.
RIGHT SEE NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND AND I THIS MOTION
IS WITH RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
SENATE AND AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED AND AND WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE A VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO THE MOTIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S AN
AMENDMENT THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS
BE CONCURRED IN.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
CHECK WORKS OF AYE AYE SIR ALAN
BERMAN.
BERMAN I CERVANTES GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE RODRIGUEZ
STEINORTH.
STAND WITH A VOTING.
ALRIGHT WITHOUT TEHAMA WITH. FOR
THE KNOW WE'RE GONNA HOLD OF OF
ROLE OPEN AND THIS IS OUR LAST
MEETING SO WE DO WANT TO THANK --
THE TEAM HERE THAT HAS WORKED
WITH JEDI AND THAT WOULD BE THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS POLICY STAFF
JULIA CAME.
AND OF COURSE THE JEDI COMMITTEE
STAFF BENJAMIN OR HEIGHT AND
TONI SIMON'S WHO WORKED
TIRELESSLY AND ARE GREAT --
COMMITTEE MEMBERS VICE CHAIR
MISTER ALLEN WHO'S NOT HERE A
MISTER BERMAN AND MR STEINORTH
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
ALSO FOR OUR SERGEANTS ERICA --
I DON'T SEE HER HERE TODAY.
THERE SHE IS AYE ERICA.
AND JOHN SIMON THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SO WILL HOLD THE VOTE
THE ROLE OPEN [inaudible]
FOR HE HAD.
HAD AN OPEN THE ROLE.
PLACER ALAN CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE RODRIGUEZ.
BUT WE'RE STILL KEEPING THE ROLE
OPEN.
FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible]
HIGHER.
FRANKLY I THINK [inaudible]
NUMERO [inaudible]
MY LOWER [inaudible]
WELL I WATER [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WE'RE
OPEN UP THE ROLE.
PLACER ALLEN.
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
MOTION AS WITH RECOMMENDATION
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN.
VICE CHAIR ALAN RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I WELL WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT
ROLE KELLY IS [inaudible] FIVE
ZERO WITH ONE NON VOTING.
OKAY THANK YOU EVERYBODY WE'VE
APPRECIATED WORKING WITH YOU.
THANKS TO SEE JULIA